- Oh, wait.
What have you got
right there, Shannon,
on the other side of that truck?
Is that a Firebird?
SHANNON: I can't see.
Let's go see what they got.
Is your dad home?
- That is a Firebird, huh?
- Yeah.
Look at me, man.
How are you doing?
Good.
We just wanted to talk
to you about your car.
Is that all right?
I'm Kevin.
Hi, Kevin.
I'm Drew.
Drew, nice to meet you.
Shannon, nice
to meet you, Drew.
Nice to meet you.
Have you had this
thing for a while?
Your dad bought
this brand new in '67?
Wow.
1967 was a year of firsts.
The first "Rolling
Stone" magazine
was published, the world's
first heart transplant
surgery was
performed, and Pontiac
released the first Firebirds.
It was the beginning
of 35 years of success
for this model, which
sold more than two million
cars throughout its run.
It looks like
it's in great shape.
There's no heavy rust around
the windows or anything.
They're usually tore up.
- You want to see the engine?
- Sure.
Yeah.
I just dumped some money into
the engine, and transmission,
all the power train stuff.
Yeah, you would never
tell by the outside, huh?
Yeah.
It's a wolf in
sheep's clothing.
So what are your plans
on this whole thing?
Next step was going to be all
my interior, weather stripping,
and then all the upholstery.
But not full
body, rest though?
I'd like to.
I just don't got
the money for it.
This is in great shape.
So it's not like you got to
go in and replace panels.
It's been a fun car.
He handed it to
me when I was 17.
So I've had it since this.
This was my daily driver for--
So you drove this
to high school?
You must have been the man.
I was in a lot of trouble.
You never wrecked it?
Never wrecked it.
Wow, beautiful car.
So no way you're
selling it, right?
- No, I don't want to sell it.
- You know what?
If you decide you want
to do the interior work,
or you want to do any paint
work, that's what we do.
Appreciate it, man.
[interposing voices]
- Have a good one.
- Thanks.
You guys too.
SHANNON: I can't
stop looking at it.
KEVIN: I know.
I know.
You want to be able to show
the boys, look what we found.